so this is just a cable news show we
never pretend that we're an
international feminist organization
we're not an ngo
but that doesn't mean we don't care
about the fate of women and girls we do
care and that's why for months now we've
been monitoring the situation in
congressman eric swalwell's office so
all you remember had a long time sexual
affair with a chinese spy that included
personal behavior we will
euphemistically describe as stomach
turning and unnatural we'll leave it at
that
so while a spy girlfriend has since fled
back to china ahead of the doj
but eric swalwell himself remains at
large tonight in both washington and
california we've been keeping tabs on
him because we think it's our duty a few
months ago we told you about suaville's
efforts to find young women who might be
willing to quote expand his brand
whatever that might mean just saying the
words makes the hair on her arm stand up
now tonight there is this development
suawell has been caught advertising for
still more women his offices posted a
quote job listing possibly on craigslist
we can't be sure noting that young women
are quote strongly encouraged to join
him and we're quoting here to manage his
agenda
verbatim quote how'd you like your
daughter managing eric suavo's agenda
how is behavior like this allowed in
2021 in the united states congress
where's nancy pelosi
if this was afghanistan if it was
happening in kandahar cnn would be
demanding that these women these agenda
managers receive immediate asylum for
their own safety un agencies would get
involved we would all understand this as
a pressing human rights crisis but
because eric swalwell is doing it manage
my agenda it's okay no it's not okay
it's wrong and we hope it stops
immediately
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else